special agent john hartley fbi  been tracking your scores for a while  now  every city  every heist  now that you've been tagged  with red notices  you become the world's most wanted  criminals  and i'm the only one who can bring you  in  where'd you get that jacket it's a  statement piece somewhere there's a very  nude cow whispering  [Applause]  [Music]  looking for something specific or just  browsing you're under arrest oh my god  i just want the egg  [Music]  help me catch her and i will help you  teamwork  and direct you know we get there  team team  team which feels weird in my mouth  [Music]  hello boys  how's it going with your partner in  crime we're work-wise we're not  worthwhile  we're not any kind of wives  we both know that this whole thing is  going to end  with you in handcuffs  promises  promises  by buyer john john hartley  [Music]  you